I'm just going to play tuba music and film you walking. Dude,
that's crazy. That's a crazy thing to say to your friend. What?
>> You said that cuz you're protecting the bag. You said
that cuz you're allied with the clients. >> You guys are
such hypocrites. I really don't like how hypocritical you are.
You can't admit that Anisa took a swing and she landed, okay?
She landed a haymaker on Ela's jaw.
>> Another Sleepy video on Nicholas
>> Oh my god. >> Thanks. Welcome back to another
video on the Sleepy channel. Yesterday was likely the most terminally
online I've been in years. Typically with this YouTube channel,
I like to pour in maybe an hour, hour and a half into these videos.
Um, maybe throw a couple tweets and then move on with the rest
of my day. That was not the case yesterday. As many of you know,
I've had my issues with Nicholas Deorio for months at this point.
I mean, for the better part of a year, he's been like incessantly
making streams and essentially A-logging the enemies of Ethan
Klein while offering little to no pushback on literally anything
Ethan Klein's been doing this year. And frankly, like that's
probably my biggest issue with him. Obviously, you can go into
the individual aspects >> Uh, no, excuse me. When Ethan
Klein like pointed out that Starkers are bait Starkers basically
killed that fox lady, Nicholas Deorio was like, "Ah, I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THAT, ETHAN." And then he continued to snark on everybody
else,
Is that not valuable pushback? When he was like, "AH, I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THAT, ETHAN. I don't know if that's true." And then
he just continued on with the regular regularly scheduled programming.
That's pretty strong pushback, right? "Ah, Ethan, I don't know
about that one, Ethan. Ethan might even be wrong there." And
then he just went on with what he was doing. >> likes of
the critiques that he offers to people. But my biggest issue
is that it's so clear that he has just picked a side that is
financially rewarding and is digging his feet in as hard as he
possibly can. And I got to hand it to him. Last year, he made
a couple hundred thousand dollars in donations. The other day,
I saw him make $600 US in 3 minutes on stream. Individual viewers
are sending this guy $200 on stream. It's ridiculous. With financial
incentives this great, how can you switch away from being a Ethan
Klein cocksuck? >> By the way, uh I don't even know if
Trisha Paytas knows. This is the argument I was making from the
very beginning with Nick. I was like, "Yeah, I get it." When
I was doing basically the same thing in the Destiny community
that Nick does for the H3 community, okay?
I was making
thousands of dollars, okay?
Quite regularly.
I'm not going to lie to you guys. Like, October, November of
2025,
2024, sorry.
There were nights
where I'm not joking, like over a thousand dollars in a night.
Okay? The monetary incentives are totally insane and very difficult
for somebody to grapple with. They're just difficult to grapple
with, okay? They are very, very, very hard to grapple with. And
I have to get a real job? No, I'm going to keep doing this. I
still Trust me, the monetary incentive here is quite good. >> You
can look at Nick Deorio's history as a content creator. This
is the most money he's ever made. It's the most attention he's
ever had. It's hard to move away from that. It's crazy to say
this given Nick Deorio's physical dimensions, but he is one of
the most successful orbiters I have ever seen. The issue is he's
orbiting a dying star and he's trying to convince you that this
is a totally normal, healthy star that is not sending fireballs
at everyone that looks at it wrong. It's how a guy that was doing
impressions of Ethan Klein just a couple years ago >> Oh,
no, but do you hear Tommy do the Ethan Klein voice and stuff
like that?
>> He found a clip of Nicholas doing an Ethan impression.
Surely this won't be a problematic or offensive at all, right?
Surely he won't sound like a complete
when he does the voice. >> Yeah, he did that today. You
guys did this tonight. Uh Tommy gets on there and goes, "Hey,
Keemstar.
So, maybe you should start being a little
>> That's the way he worded >> That's not even
That doesn't sound anything like Hila Klein. What? >> Tommy
is a >> We're going to get Tommy to start doing >> good
I still don't understand why Tommy's Israel voice is racist.
I don't get it.
>> You don't Wait, Augie doesn't get it.
How did How did Augie not get it? I thought Augie was the guy
who said, "Obviously it's offensive."
What? >> You know what I mean? >> I was in the military
and now I am wondering why Keemstar is so mean to
>> By the way, this is doing an Israeli accent. That doesn't
sound like Hila
That I Like just an Israeli accent doesn't sound anything like
Hila Klein. >> is now clutching his pearls saying that
Anisa Jomha's impression of Hila Klein is offensive. >> I'm
a big fan of Nicholas DeOrio. What can I say? You do your research.
>> I don't know. >> Not only is that offensive, it's
also bad. Like it's a bad impression. >> It's the same
guy, but different incentives. Now, let's get to the meat of
the video. AugieRFC had a reply to my tweet that I disagreed
with because I don't like the spirit of it. Now, I understand
what Augie's doing, okay? Augie's offering a perspective that
kind of defends his friend. And I >> By the way,
and I I hate to say I hate to call Augie out a little bit, but
Augie replied to every single person, it seemed like, who talked
who asked him a question about his tweet, except me. He dodged
every He He dodged
my reply and answered every other one.
That was very concerning to me, cuz I asked the correct question
immediately, all right? I think Chilepi has all these in the
but I asked the correct question,
and he dodged my question.
>> I think Augie's being a good friend in doing this. I
just I disagree with what he's saying, and if I'm giving my read
of it, I think Augie's being a little dishonest in this tweet.
However, I will say once again, I understand he is trying to
be a good friend. So, I'm I'm willing to give him the pass, okay?
So, let's get into this chronologically. I've already shown you
the clip, but we'll play it again cuz I >> How long we
sticking with the Shia cleric penguin?
Maybe until the war ends? I don't know. Maybe I'm just liking
it. Maybe I Maybe I've been doing Maybe I've been binging Shia
propaganda, okay?
And I'm starting to really get into the >> That's what
happened first. >> I'm a big fan of Nicholas DeOrio. What
can I say? You do your research.
>> I don't know. >> Not only is that offensive, >> just
keep watching it over and over >> DeOrio calls it offensive
and bad. Mocking someone's accent  second language speaking
is offensive to most communities partaking in targeting Ela this
way. That's not really an opinion, either. There is a huge double
standard in what people are allowed to ethically mock. So, that
first paragraph is different to what he said on stream. On stream,
he said that's offensive and it's bad. >> I don't know.
>> I know. >> Not only is that offensive, it's also
bad. Like, it's a bad impression. >> I said I had one.
That's my That's my Ela impression. >> That sounds like
a character from What's What character is this from um from from
The Simpsons?
>> Well, I think it's Barney.
>> We're We're now 20 seconds past him saying that it was
offensive. There isn't no claim of hypocrisy yet because it wasn't
in his brain. It wasn't what
>> He said it's offensive because his reflexive response
is to defend Ela Klein, defend the Klein. >> Yes. Oh.
It was Did you see me watching the stream yesterday?
He is That's his first instinct is I'm just going to Oh my god,
they're they're attacking THE KLEIN. NO, THAT'S OFFENSIVE. DON'T
ATTACK MY PATRONS. Don't do it. Don't do it. >> all costs.
Figure it out later. Rationalize it later. The hypocrisy argument
wasn't in his mind. He was thinking, "Bad thing said about Ethan
This must be anti-Semitism. This must be offensive. This must
be something >> It sounds like Barney from Is it Barney?
It was like the fat guy.
Oh, oh my god. You're being very anti-Semitic right now. >> Let's
cool it with the anti-Semitism.
>> When you're getting down to like, "Oh, this impression
from Anisa is anti-Semitic." You've hit like bedrock, okay? You've
hit bedrock.
You've hit bedrock.
You know what? This actually Oh, that's a good one. She sounds
like the bear from The Cleveland Show. But, you're saying Apu
cuz she's doing like a weird Everything she does sounds like
a weird Muslim accent, too. >> Now we're calling it a weird
Muslim accent. Again, it has nothing to do with Anisa being hypocritical
to her leftist
This is just a post-talk rationalization that Nick DiOrio is
trying to offer so that it doesn't seem like he was being a on
stream. Because guess what? He was being a on stream. But, let's
continue. We're a minute and 4 seconds in. Let's see if in the
next minute he says anything else. >> Her only concept
of accents is doing like a Muslim thing. >> It's friend
of Nicholas DiOrio. What can >> Well, actually a little
Indian maybe, >> Hey, you do you. She sounds like she's
about to explain why I need to >> DiOrio can't tell if
it's Indian, can't tell if it's Muslim, can't tell whatever it
is, okay? To me, when I hear this, well, I think, "Wow, she's
impersonating >> to join Metro PCS with a new talk and
text plan. >> research with full unlimited data. >> Yeah,
it kind of is the bear. I mean, this is not even a good impression.
Nick is going to make so much freaking money, yeah. >> Oh,
no.
That was the famous Elon That was, yeah. It kills at parties.
I had a poker event that I did that at, and it did kill. So.
>> That surprises me that they can actually house a party.
Like, you're so mentally by Heela Kliyne that you actually just
do impressions of her at parties with your friends who are probably
I just love
I love what I see
people use like my language. Like things that I'm been putting
up in the zeitgeist for like a long time, yeah.
Mental cognitive stuff. Every single time. I just like seeing
it. It's like I know you've been watching. I know you've been
watching.
I see you. >> Not online. >> Not online people. >> You
love to see it.
Nick was not happy. I don't know if I have any albums of the
the messages, but he was not happy about the tweets, you >> Party.
Now she's pretending to go to poker parties just like Heela.
Oh my Yeah, wait. That's a Dude, oh another
vicariously living through >> The hypocrisy argument was
nowhere near his brain. He had to figure out, how can I make
myself not look like a massive for saying that this was offensive.
Oh, I'm going to call it a hypocrisy argument that was clearly
not something I was thinking about. So, when Augie says, "Objectively
it is if Heela was black and Anisa was like, man, what you doing?"
That would be hilarious.
>> See. Hey, man, what you doing?
Why didn't he lean into that? >> Because it's offensive.
I don't think Nick is suddenly disavowing offensive humor. It's
obviously a hypocrisy argument because Anisa is a woke scolding
leftist. >> I The best case scenario here, okay? I hope
Augie is watching this AT HOME. THE BEST CASE scenario here is
that Augie was just like, "I'm bored. I'm going to go piss some
people off." I think that's the best case scenario. I think that's
why he didn't respond to me, to be honest with Cuz I think
I That's the best case scenario, right? He's just like, "Nah,
[__] it. I'm going to go piss some people off right
now. I'm going to pull the broom out. I'm going to piss some
people off." >> Again, that was nowhere near what he said
in the clip. This is all post-talk rationalization. This is all
an excuse that we come up with after the fact so that we don't
look like fools. My issue was never is this offensive or is it
not offensive. My issue is why did you say it was offensive?
What made the ultimate
>> Because you needed all of those wine moms to basically
be on your side. That's what you're looking for, right? That's
what he's looking for there. He wants all of the H3 wine moms
to be on his side to to say, "Oh yeah, Nick called this out.
Nick called it correctly.
This was very offensive. That was very anti-Semitic.
Thank you for calling it out, Nicholas De Orio. Thank you. >> review
guys say, "Ooh, guys, this is too far. This is offensive. Why
did you say that?" You said that cuz you're protecting the bag.
You said that cuz you're allied with the clients. That's the
only reason. So, give me a break with all this, "Oh, they're
woke scolding leftists. They shouldn't be saying this. They're
hypocrites." You know what I think? I think it was a funny impression.
I think everybody thinks it was a funny impression. And this
guy had to figure out a way to make it not seem funny. So, he
said that it was offensive. You know why? Because he's not allowed
to find it funny. I also find it so annoying that these people
keep coming back to, "They're woke scolding leftists. They're
not allowed to ever say anything funny or >> That that
is really what it comes down to. You're not allowed to find it
funny. You know you're not allowed to find it funny. You know
you have to hate everything Anisa does, it doubly so when it
attacks Ela. You're you're literally not allowed to join the
club and so you spitefully try to make it racist cuz you're a
All right? You can't admit that Ela, sorry, that's that Anisa
took a swing and she landed it, okay? She landed a haymaker on
Ela's
You can't do it. >> edgy ever again. Even though they've
been crying and begging for these people to be edgy for years.
I'm going to explain this two ways. One way that I believe and
one way that's a leftist type of belief. I think we need to start
by saying that was not a impression, that was an Ela Klein impression.
And Ela Klein is Israeli.
>> He was he was having >> Klein simply sounds funny.
She has a very goofy sounding voice, okay? It is comical that
somebody with her voice has landed herself in a successful position
in podcasting. Now, as for your woke scolding left >> Even
Sleepy sleeping, okay? Even Sleepy sleeping here. What does she
sound like? She sounds like Mama [__] She sounds
cognitively impaired. That's why it's funny to all of us, because
she sounds like an actual
Okay? She sounds like she has Down syndrome. Even though she
doesn't, she sounds like she has Down syndrome, okay?
That's what makes it funny. >> Leftists, they're not allowed
to make fun of people. As Nick says, the caveat is that it's
fair game to do this if the person is hated enough. Ian and Anisa
have moved on from edgelords to woke scolds, but constantly fall
back on tactics they used before. No bad tactics, only bad targets.
I reject that concept, but if we're going to go down that path,
Israel has systemically oppressed Palestinians for decades. They
have butchered over 70,000 people in just over 2 years. They
are genociding Palestinians. I think it's a pretty woke lefty
thing to make fun of systemically oppressive people. So, if you
want to go down the road of hypocrisy,
in their own
>> Oh, sure. Yeah, I didn't I didn't think they'd make
this argument, but sure. I'm pretty sure making fun of Nazis
would be totally fine, right? Like literally some pejorative
way to make fun of Nazis, you're doing a German accent and making
them sound stupid. All of these people would be totally down
with this, right? Obviously. >> definitely would not be.
And that's if you're under the impression that Anisa is making
fun of Israelis generally, rather than just impersonating Ela.
My perspective, you can be a leftist and still make fun of somebody's
stupid voice, especially when that person has been up your ass
for the better part of a year. Oh, but but Sleepy, Items always
talks about empathy and and Anisa they they always talk about
empathy and going
>> Yeah, well, what did empathy get them by the way? Empathy
got them start for like 2 years. Okay, empathy, turning the other
cheek, turns out the Christian approach got them in the ass repeatedly.
Right? That's what the empathetic approach got them. Maybe it's
time for them to stop taking the empathetic approach. Maybe Anisa
decided, "Hey, you know what? Today it stops. Today it stops,
okay?
I'm hitting back as of today. >> Yeah, dude. Yeah, dude.
That like you can have a general rule set that you use for everybody
in your life. But when you have a group of enemies that makes
content about you non-stop for like an entire year, I think that
those general rules can go out the door when you're approaching
people that absolutely want to [__] with you and
mess with your life. I'm not going to be able to find this clip,
but there's a clip out there of Ethan Klein saying, "This will
never be over. That he will never find peace with Idubbbz. always
hate Idubbbz." You're expecting Anisa to take that sitting down
and and not throw some shade back. "Oh, they're leftist. They're
supposed to take it in the ass." Frankly, like I find this [__]
so
>> Holy [__] I'm like mind melding with this.
We're like mind melding right now, Sleepy. We're mind melding,
okay?
Yes. Yes. >> are are these edge lords yourselves and you're
like, "Well, well, they're supposed to be woke scolding leftists.
Like they're being hypocrites." Okay, dude. Okay, who gives a
[__] Like I really really this is this is your issue?
Like Augie's in my comments saying that he's I don't care cuz
I'm racist, but that's how people see it. Pointing out that something
is offensive doesn't mean that you find it problematic. Dude,
again.
>> No, hold on. That's actually just wrong. Nothing is
objectively offensive. Offense is literally subjective.
There is no This is like saying something is objectively funny.
Okay, you might say that cuz you're trying to argue it is something
is funny, but nothing is objectively funny. It is all up to the
subject to determine if it's funny or not.
Nothing is objectively offensive.
When you say it's offensive, you are saying it offends me as
the subject. I am I am subject to that impression and it offends
me. That is what you are
>> He clearly found it problematic and he clearly did not
think about the hypocrisy argument when he played this >> I'm
a big fan of Nicholas Deorio. What can I say? You do your research.
>> I don't know. >> I know. >> Not only is
that offensive, it's also bad. Like it's a >> Again, and
we play the entire thing. Not once in this clip was he thinking,
"This is kind of hypocritical." He wasn't even thinking about
that. It's a post-hoc rationalization. So, we should be throwing
that whole hypocrisy argument out to begin with. But, I'm only
engaging with it because of you, Augie, because you've decided
to double down and because you're trying to defend your boy and
I get it. That's your homie, you're trying to be a good friend,
but do not let this guy make you think that he was doing this
for any other reason than he was defending Ethan Klein's honor
because that's what it was. He's not allowed to find that funny.
In that >> Hold on. That's a That's a very kind way to
say that, okay? That's because when it comes to Ethan Klein,
Ethan Klein looks like Sorry, Nicholas Deorio looks like Ethan
Klein the same way that Hutch looks at Soy Boy or any other attractive
man, okay? He wants to use their as a [__] soft serve
ice cream machine. All right? That's what Nicholas Deorio wants
to do. All right? He wants to eat just shovel the [__]
from the Klein's into Nicholas Deorio's mouth. That sustains
him, okay? That's what he's looking to do. >> If he laughs,
if he thinks that's a really good impression, actually, his audience
will tear him apart. He's not allowed to find what Anisa is saying
funny and he definitely can't laugh at Anisa impersonating Ethan
Klein. And Augie, let me be clear. Forget about this clipped
live uh post that he's doing, the post-talk rationalization.
There is no way, and we played the full 2 minutes, there is no
way that in the clip itself, you got the impression that Diorio
was talking about a hypocrisy argument. You only got that from
what he said in the clip live, but you did not get that from
his stream because he did not say that and he wasn't thinking
it. He said that it was offensive for completely different reasons.
So, yeah. Like I said, I don't agree with what Augie said here.
I >> It's just a whole 'nother case of Nicholas basically
doing something, saying something on stream, and then once he
realizes he looks like a total
for the clients. The second he realized that he goes, "Oh, I
need a different explanation." And he comes up with something,
okay?
>> think. Obviously, I don't agree with what Nick said.
I don't I think Nick is I think Nick's making it up as he goes
along. I think Nick knows he's a dead man walking, channel-wise,
of course. Like, let me be clear, channel-wise. And I want to
point out some comments that I agree with here. Jay Stalk goes,
"Is there more to the clip that's cut off that makes it clearly
a hypocrisy argument?" The Reddit >> This is the only comment
he didn't respond to, by the way. The comment that completely
points out exactly why it's wrong to sweep here. Right? Hey,
what what did you see in the clip that made you think this? What
did you see in how he presented himself to those disgusting,
wretched H3 wine moms? What part of that part Well, that clip
made you think that it was a hypocrisy
Oh, no part. Just the the sweep after the fact. That's all it
is. Okay, sure. >> comment. So, after the fact, he said
something different. Again, the clip itself, he is clearly not
talking about hypocrisy. Not Chronic Sonic says, "I thought you
guys were dying for Ian and Anissa to do edgy humor again. I'm
all for it." >> I didn't see I didn't say I wasn't in my
I was talking [__] about Augie hoping he would join
my Discord and
just hoping he'd be he'd have tuned in and checked out stream
and he might have hopped and then I just realized I'm not in
my Discord at all. >> Argus, I'm all for it regardless
of how hypocritical they look. >> It's so
soy. You guys are hypocrites. You guys You guys said that you're
done with the edgy stuff and now you're >> Oh my god, you
guys are like total hypocrites.
Okay? I need you to stop being such hypocrites.
Respect the people in this great state of Israel. >> Being
edgy again. >> You [__] like don't >> He
was doing the voice. That's not my fault. That was Chlewy who
was doing the voice. I just picked up the thread, okay? He was
doing the voice first. >> [__] piss your pants.
>> Listen to that. >> [__] soy. You guys
are hypocrites.
>> You guys are such hypocrites. I really don't like how
hypocritical you are. >> Guys, you guys said that you're
done with the edgy stuff and now you're being edgy again. You
[__] like don't your pants over the >> And
here's the other thing, there's no real like hallmarks of anti-Semitism
here, right? Like uh maybe if Anissa did oy vey and the merchant
hands, you know what I mean? I listen, those are like stereotypical
offensive things to do and that are considered anti-Semitic,
right? She wasn't doing >> Wait, kind of like hold on.
Kind of like uh kind of like this? >> Then you do this.
Okay? I didn't do the meme. I didn't do the meme. I'm just saying
this, okay? This is the Larry Ellison. Hey, give me TikTok, work
for Israel. Give me CBS, work for Israel. Give me the American
government. Give me the American
Dude, I it blows me away how Chank like doesn't sound It's like
you can't tell he's doing anything remotely anti-Semitic and
then he just starts like rolling off all this zog talk, okay?
It's so funny. Anna does do it better, yes, that's true, but
while Anna does it better,
Chank doing it is so funny because of like the things he says
just immediately go to like the most zog [__] the
most like zogged talking points that exist. >> She was
clearly impersonating Ela, not Israelis as a whole, and not definitely
not Jews. Listen, Augie, I I I get it, you know, it's your buddy,
but I'm telling you, get off this DiOrio train. I know he's in
the the Discord chats. I know he's in the group chat saying,
"This sleepy guy, we got to do something about this." If you
genuinely are watching that clip and thinking, "Oh, he's he's
talking about hypocrisy. Oh, he's he's he's making an argument
here." You've lost the plot. I don't I don't believe that you've
lost the plot. Like I said, I think you're being a good friend.
I think you saw what he said in clip live. I'm sure he sent you
some texts, and you threw out a tweet that frankly I I don't
agree with. I think it's a bit of a silly take, but it is what
it is. Anyways, ladies and gents, if you enjoyed today's video
and you want to see more like it, leave a like, comment, and
subscribe, and I'll see you in the next video.
>> Uh what the [__] >> Yeah, Keemstar.
>> What a weird time to tune into a Pisco video. Wrong.
Wrong.
Some brave patriot has found a couple of Nicholas DiOrio timestamps
to laugh at, so let's uh let's go ahead and watch some of these,
okay?
>> I feel like
I only thought about it recently, but isn't this like a racist
like old-school DEPICTION OF LIKE >> YES!
DUDE. DUDE. DUDE.
>> The goat. >> Ethan is Jim Crow coded. He realizes
that Jim Crow is currently on Anissa's >> How? I don't
>> The Jim Crow. What? He thinks this crow is racist?
Wait, is there a is there a Jim Crow? Is there an actual Jim
Crow? Like a crow that is Jim Crow? This is apparently Jim Crow
right here.
The crows from Dumbo.
But are those crows are those actually right? I don't know. Are
those crows actually supposed to be right? That was Freudian
on my part. Whoops. Whoops. Shouldn't be thinking about that
much. My bad. My bad. Let me reset. Let me pull back and reset
after that Freudian slip. Hold on. Okay, I'm ready. I'm ready.
We're back. We're back. We're
They're obviously black coded. Okay. I I can't see it, but I'm
guessing you'd see it in the mannerisms, right?
I mean, I haven't seen Dumbo in a long time. I don't remember
the crows being racist, but they could be racist. I don't know.
It's just goofy to make the comparison. It's just more neuroticism
that makes no sense. Just very embarrassing to make these comparisons.
Everything they do is racist. He sounds like every woke lefty
he would have made fun of. He sounds like Kephals is who he sounds
like.
Like that's who he sounds like right
He's like Kephals or one of these super far lefty demon mama
types. That's what he sounds like, bro. He's become that which
he swore to destroy. >> it recently, but isn't this like
a racist like old school depiction of like how like >> Isn't
this the Jim Crow?
>> Yeah, I think uh >> If you reach like how they
reach. >> I'm serious. >> I think about like When
you think about like Dumbo and these old >> Dude, he's
talking about Dumbo. He's so Jim Crow coded. >> Disney
movies where they're like they're like oh dude, that was so [clears throat]
[__] up how we like made those crows like like it
looks like those ones. I don't know. >> And so he Nicholas
is just laughing along and agreeing that it seems racist.
Right? He's just like a fat lefty. He is literally demon mama.
He's like one He's like one bad makeup job away from just being
demon mama. >> Oh, I mean, I'm just >> That's that
was what I thought cuz it's just so so >> Obviously nobody
is saying that Anissa walked into her tattoo parlor and went,
"I'm a >> No, you are saying that and you're agreeing with
them. That is exactly what you're trying to point out.
Now you're running away from it cuz you know it sounds like >> big
fan of the racist depic- the racist crows from the old Disney
movies, but it is funny to make fun of her tattoos,
>> Random, like just some strange >> I don't think
that Anissa secretly like hates black people or something and
she's trying to hide it through tattoos on her body. >> Looking
bird. But I don't think she hates black people. That's what >> Okay,
yeah, but good good good. >> I don't think she hates black
people. It's just like clearly that's a racist tattoo and like
it's funny that she has it. And I don't think she hates black
people. I don't think she's anti-Semitic, but it's like kind
of weird how she is saying this woman smells like pennies and
like that she's doing it an Israeli impression.
Dude, these people are cowards on top of
Very goofy. Okay, whatever. Whatever. Whatever. I guess I guess
you just get to go back on that after saying
Okay. Okay. You know what? I'm going to let that one go. Let
that one go. He kind of went back on it after the fact. 2 hours
and 6 minutes.
More more of the racism claims. Hold on. 2 hours 6 minutes 50.
>> I'm not saying she hates black people. >> I didn't
say anything about that. >> Frankly, I've never had a conversation
like that before with them. >> I know you know what? Me
neither and now that's pretty suspect. >> But I'm not saying
anything. >> Oh, wait. I'm I'm pretty far away from this.
Hold on. >> Dude, come on. >> Here we go. >> It
wasn't only about
>> Anyway, here it is Anissa.
I find it pretty creepy how quickly the new H3 members like Tamara
and Morgan are so quick to start making fun of you and Ian. Morgan
especially because she seemed so normal but then laughs the hardest
at Ethan or Dan making fun of you guys. >> You laughed
too hard. >> It's like they don't realize it's cuz you
suck. Like that's that's why people are laughing at you and making
fun of you. It's cuz you suck. >> at my jokes.
>> They're like, "Damn, I thought you were so normal until
you laughed at a professional comedian in his prime." [laughter]
>> Oh, I just >> Did you just laugh at that?
He just Did he just laugh at that? >> at a professional
comedian in his
>> Oh, I
>> I can't tell. Is he snarking
He's laughing at the fact that Ethan called himself a professional
comedian, right? That's got to be hopefully hopefully that's
what it is. >> reading a super chat. I was so confused
as to what she was even like I thought she was just saying you
and Ian and I was like who who?
>> Who am I laughing at? >> Me. Yeah. I'll play I
want you I want you to stop having Don't have any fun. >> Yes,
stop. Stop. >> Who is the mole? I There's no mole. Actually,
someone did have a theory.
There was a game theory that popped up and I was like Nah. Someone's
like, was it the former moderator that we covered a couple of
months ago? Like the crazy mod who was like, I'm trying to like
contact a lawyer. Like, dude, that
>> You guys know I I can't tell. Have I introduced my audience
to Glam?
You guys know who the girl with the microphone is?
Some people call her Nicole Diorio, all
Does Does the audience know? I feel like the audience doesn't
know who
girl with a microphone.
The girl with a microphone. Some call her Nicole Diorio,
She basically Nicholas Diorio coded. >> What's up, guys?
I'm here in the car. WE'RE GOING TO PHILLY. >> LIKE unironically
very very very very
Nicholas Diorio coded, okay? They're like kind of the same person
more or
All right?
Feel a little more comfortable with who she is, but it is what
it is, all right?
>> I'm sad. >> Getting a Reuben?
Some awesome? It looks just like it They They really do look
alike. It's actually uncanny, okay? She was very upset that Anissa
was going and making fun of these people for being fat, all right?
I don't I don't know if I covered all of this stuff today. Or
sorry, I don't know if I've covered this stuff before. I was
looking at it today. I wasn't even going to go over it, but had
It has been a lot of crying, okay?
So, Anissa tweeted, "I guess he didn't like people pointing out
that he looks like a chode with arms. This is the Anisa tweet,
okay?
And Gwenn tweets
Gwenn tweets from the Gwenn tweets
Oh, wow. More fat phobia from the moral authority Anisa Jomo.
What a cool and interesting person she is. Now, one, everybody
around Gwenn calls people fat, okay? Harley, Ethan, Nick, everybody
everybody makes fun of other people for being fat. For one thing,
okay? I believe I wouldn't be shocked if she did it, too. All
right? And then I think we should have some Somebody put their
their pictures into AI, okay? Match 84%
Basically, look, they're looking Score of greater than or equal
to 50% usually means it's likely the same
It's [__] up. It's just [__] up, okay?
They're like, "Dude, where is the estrogen post?" Guys, this
is 2 years on HRT. What do you guys think? 2 years on HRT. Where's
the post? It has to exist, right? It has to exist somewhere,
okay? So, I just want to point She was about how people are treating
Nick Fuentes. I do think it'd be funny to go and find some of
the tweets. I might go find them after this, okay? I was being
sent them all day. I didn't like them. I was mostly following
the Joe Kent stuff and playing Civ. But, mostly following the
Joe Kent stuff. I didn't follow this stuff as much.
All right. No wonder he stopped camming up. Well, I think I think
what's happening is Nick Fuentes is losing a bunch of weight.
And I think Nick Fuentes is going to cam up in the near future.
I think he wants to do like something of a Nick Fuentes avocado
reveal that he's lost like 200 lb.
I think that's what's going to happen. I think so. We're I'm
not 100% sure, but I do believe that's what's going to
We'll see.
Okay, we got one more time stamp on this vod. I >> That
could be I don't know if I can see that. >> That's one
that listen, I wouldn't
That could be the one, but I don't think
I find >> Ray Ray Famal or whatever, yeah. >> it
pretty creepy how quickly the >> What's creepy? What is
their obsession with the word creepy? >> creepy. I just
like Tamara and Morgan are so quick to start making fun of you
and Ian Morgan especially because >> That's the only person
even tangentially related to the H3 podcast that I could see
be like delivering info on the back >> Because she seemed
>> Or it would be something where like AB was trying to
play both sides earlier on in like good faith.
Play both sides, but you know what I mean. Maybe they were messages
from like 6 months ago where he was trying to like ease tensions.
I could see that
>> Okay, hold on. I I'm over done. We're done. We're done
with this. Uh 2 hours 15. We're done with this section. >> I
will just be a paypig.
>> See that? Hello. >> donated $3.
Bro can't even take one step. How he going to be two steps >> Yeah,
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. Thank you very much
for the
I Listen, I don't want to get straight up into like totally bullying,
but
Well, where's the I'm not going to be able to find that in my
Oh, hold on. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait.
I actually have to find something to play on this real quick.
>> is, you know, >> I just think Anus is not really
good at navigating this. >> It's It's That's the things
that they do. So, after she already said that on the first stream,
now on the third stream she's saying to Mars smells like
>> Mhm. Yep. >> It's just a little bit much. >> are
painted as evil, if you're evil people, then they could say whatever
they want about you even if it's so [__] up because
they have painted you as evil. And once you're literally evil,
anything bad could be said, anything, whatever they want because
>> I've I've gone on this argument line before and I've
explained like this is the reason why
uh being like falsely labeled as like a destiny like I other
people have had this before. Being falsely labeled as like a
destiny defender
or something is such a crazy concept because there's like a install
base of people being like, "Oh, this guy defends Destiny." They
don't go for what or what it what they talked about or "Oh, this
guy I like a fan in the past." They go, "Oh, this guy defends
Destiny. That means this guy is a
like he's pro >> Oh god, he's going to he's going to run
down the whole Billy Mac thing that he tried to stay out of,
isn't he? He's going to go, "Oh, this guy Somebody docks this
guy. Docks and kill this guy right now. >> people's [__]
tapes and [__] Pro [__] pro revenge You
have to like um perjure yourself or you have to commit defamation
to defend yourself from that argument or whatever.
>> What? You have to perjure yourself or commit defamation
to defend yourself from that argument.
What the [__] does that mean? >> defamation
to defend yourself from that argument or whatever. Um but you're
>> What the [__] is he even saying? What does
this mean?
Can anybody explain what this means to
You lie? That's a perjure yourself. You don't have to lie. Dude,
that is what perjure
yourself means. You have to lie to defend yourself from that
argument. You have to lie about what? Okay, that's odd.
You're like ontologically >> evil. So, at that point they
can just docks you. They can mentally
uh they can go after you. They can [__]
uh spam all your tweets and report all your videos and stuff
because you're ontologically evil. >> Cuz that's evil and
it's good versus evil in their brains or whatever narrative they're
trying to spin up. Someone mentioned um an alternate explanation
explanation for the penny reference could be menstrual blood,
which is I guess a sorry about that. Uh misogyny, so it could
be anti-Semitism or misogyny. You can pick
How did Dick turn this into He He's listening to like the the
extreme JN from these people trying to take the pennies comment
turn it into anti-Semitism. He's like, "Guys, people sometimes
say I defend Destiny. That means that like everyone on the internet
is allowed to docks and kill
It's like, "Okay, I
This neuroticism versus this neuroticism, who's winning out?
Sorry, somebody talked about taking one >> Blast that [__]
You go louder.
It's so quiet.
>> People are just posting a bunch of videos of Nicholas
on Twitter. It's >> Blast that [__] You go
louder.
It's so quiet. This is not working.
>> We're going to play tuba music and film you walking.
>> Wait, is that Augie? What the Didn't even listen to
the voice. I'm just going to play tuba music and film you walking?
Dude, that's crazy. That's a crazy thing to say to your friend.
What? >> Blast that [__] You go louder.
It's so quiet. This is not working.
>> We're going to play tuba music and film you walking.
>> Dude, that's Augie Tom. OH MY GOD.
DUDE, WHAT THE F
>> HOLD ON, HOLD ON, hold on. Is there Is this what I'm
looking for? >> Blast that [__] You go louder.
It's so quiet. This is not working.
>> We're going to play tuba music and film you walking.
>> Blast that [__] You go louder.
>> It's so quiet. This is not working. >> I don't
know.
I don't know what we're going for. I don't know what we're going
for there with the tuba stuff, but
I don't think that was quite it, but you know, that's close enough,
okay? That's close enough. >> Again though, I think dude,
I don't know. That would not have been my first insult line if
I was >> That is specifically what? >> looks really
bad. >> Think about that. Oh god, he's going to >> Misogyny,
so it could be >> to go further into the J and then they
[clears throat] are. No way.
>> Let's listen again. >> Again though, I think dude,
we can argue with all the other ones. The pennies one looks really
bad. Like that's just like that is specifically
I don't know. That would not have been my first >> Excuse
me, misogyny. So what do you mean I smell like pennies? Are you
implying that I like pennies more than the average person? >> insult
line if I was trying to avoid >> All right. Tina, she's
giving me permission to play it. All right.
>> I'm a big fan of Nicholas D'Orio. What can I say? YOU
DO YOUR RESEARCH.
>> YEAH. THAT will >> I might just I might just let
this play. I do want to hear him again. >> donation sound
for stream. >> I I I was just confused. Again. Again. >> What
the recent Twitter is I was I didn't know what she was doing.
>> And if Nicholas >> I love Tina. She's giving me
>> can I say?
>> Honestly, the only thing that she needs to add here
to make this a little bit more on the nose is instead of holding
her microphone, if she like puts her like you know the hand thing.
Like if she puts her then she could really sell it. >> research
[laughter] >> I Yeah. >> Got him. >> I I I
I was just confused. Again. Again. What the recent Twitter is
I was I didn't know what she was doing.
>> I [laughter] know. I wouldn't have >> And by the
way, I'm sure her I don't think anybody Okay. >> She does
that at parties? >> She does it at parties?
>> Yeah, that's insane, dude. She just shows up like, "Oh,
I got to do my iconic Hila Klein impression at >> She did
it at at a You know what's the party? She was hanging out with
Dan and and she said Dan and I loved it. >> Oh, she was
probably cackling.
>> So, [laughter] you know there was a lot of there >> Here
Here you want You want to hear my impression of Nissa? >> Hello,
my name is Anisa and I >> It It's >> You just did
a silly [laughter] voice. >> Me and Nissa
>> He's going to point the camera, right? >> She
hates Jewish people. >> You literally didn't sound anything
like her. You just did a silly voice. >> to point the camera?
No. >> It It wasn't It was It wasn't a bad >> through
this?
>> Remember I was thinking of Ed Bassmaster Marine
>> You know who's left, right? >> Yeah, you want
to be really >> funny is like if Ethan woofs >> her
little voice track right there. >> Anisa impression. I'll
do I'll do my Hila Klein impression. He's just like J. >> Let's
go. >> She's like a completely different [__]
person.
>> That's the bit he went up to him and just went
It's It was an old video, but it slapped. But anyways, I thought
I thought that's crazy that anyone told
>> Yeah, and she took the show on the road, which was ill-conceived,
but here it is. She's killing it for her 200 audience, which
is double what Ian >> Dude, where is this?
Oh my god, there's the [__] impression. Is it this
one? >> but here's Jason Statham
>> Yeah, this is it. Dude, this is such a good video. This
is a sick Jason Statham impression. Have you seen this? >> do
impressions, but here's Jason Statham
finding out that he parked his car in a handicap spot at a Target.
>> Oh, he's got to He's got to double down on the cop,
isn't he? >> And now the manager's coming out and and told
him he's got to move. Here's Jason responding to >> like
Ela. >> I can also do >> And you know what? It's
a new meme template, basically. People have been doing this a
lot.
I've been watching um
if if Barack Obama was a bird
and it's the same thing going on.
>> Dude, this actually >> I'm sorry. Uh listen, we've
got more, okay? There is more. I wasn't We're not
But my god, I just had to I just had to shut it off, okay?
Hold on. Do we Do we get every Anisa tweet on the stream? I don't
know if we got every Anisa tweet on the stream. Hold on. See
here. So, Anisa, this was the first one. Wait, this is so embarrassing.
This is the Nicholas DeOrio friend zone clip.
What else What else What else >> the ones that she's done.
Let's open them all. Oh, wow, more fat phobia from moral authority
Anisa Jomo. What a cool and interesting person she is.
There are many beautiful fat people who love their bodies. He
isn't one of them, and neither are you with that fat with that
fat bun you choose to wear every
Oh, oh, oh, oh. She's sharking girl She's sharking girl with
a microphone now, too. Oh, boy. I didn't see this one. Bro, ankles
look like they've been Bro's ankles looks like looks
Bro's ankles look like they've been pumped with salt and he needs
a lymphatic drainage stat. He looks like he has a rotation of
he has a rotation of goods that are all beige in color. Rotation
of goods that are all beige in color. That's not my problem.
Micronutrients matter. Love your body, take a multivitamin. It
autocorrected foods to goods. Oh, a rotation of foods that are
all beige in color. I see.
Nobody told me about carbs is what she's saying. She's literally
casting that at him. Nobody told me about carbs.
>> Angry woman archetype quit selling 8 years ago. You
reply to every tweet. Okay. All right. All right. All right.
What else is there?
There's this one. This one. These are all the same thing. These
are responding to my tweet. I can't stop laughing. I should have
never tweeted about this freak. My timeline has been ruined.
My God. And then yeah, it's just the same tweet. Okay. All right.
We got it. We got the Anisa tweets at him.
Okay. Now, today I believe this is today's stream,
Or this is the stream where he's like talking about people complaining
about his take. >> All I'll say is 707
is better than 730.
>> All right. 1 hour 56:15
first timestamp.
Is him explaining the
He's going to go through why his Anisa take was wrong. >> to
Ethan rather than like something that she genuinely cares about.
>> You want links for Pisco covering his ogre boy tweets?
I To be honest, I gave you my impression
about
but I I was playing Civ. I wasn't totally paying attention. I
was thinking I should look first or I should look before I go
in on it on stream. I just I Dude, dude, Nicholas Deorio, I would
pay at least $500 US for a Nicholas Deorio Guam mukbang collab.
okay? I don't particularly like it should be something saucy.
As long as it's something saucy and they do a joint mukbang,
500 bucks. I got 500 bucks. I'll dump 500 bucks for this, okay?
Nicholas DeOrio Guam mukbang collab, $500 for me, for sure, pledged.
If this should happen, okay? Damn.
Sorry, Tequila Sunset said this is the bun in question, okay?
This is the actual bun in question. Damn. I guess that's like
the best uh example I can find.
Ian [snorts] and Anissa admit to watching Nicholas DeOrio in
their spare time. E- Anissa boasts about her heel inclined impression
going viral. All right. So, this is what I wanted to talk about
uh and kind of go over what I had said on my stream cuz I saw
Oh, by the way,
he was also seething about oh, it's just the usual suspects.
These guys get mad at me about everything.
Bro, you're just being a disingenuous
we're just going to mock we're going to mock you for it every
time you do it, Every single time you have a wine mom take that
you're just you're trying to be as non-offensive as possible,
you're trying to rebrand to this like super
happy-go-lucky fat kid, okay? Every single time you complain
or sorry, every single time you do it, we're going to mock you.
Every time. Yes, it will be every single time. >> There's
also some people in the subreddit asking about it. And I kind
of already answered it while we're going over the last segment.
And we talk about this to the point of like redundancy.
I think I said on stream, the clip was this is already offensive,
but it's a bad impression as well. Like the impression was bad,
too. And I >> Yes, it's offensive is what you So, let's
just go let's just go see it, okay? Let's just go see it again.
Hold on. Let's just go see it again. Just go look again.
>> I'm a big fan of Nicholas DeOrio. What can I say? You
do your research.
>> I don't know. >> I know. >> Not only is
that offensive, it's also bad. Like it's a Not only is that offensive,
okay. >> That was not offensive. >> But it I think
I said on stream, the clip was this is already offensive, but
it's a bad impression as well. Like the impression was bad, too.
>> And that was kind of just a It wasn't >> as far
off as I Something about that made me react, and I don't know
what it was now. Phantom reaction. >> walk off and move
on point. So, let's listen to what they had to say, and I'll
explain it further, cuz I didn't think that needed an explanation,
but
>> Oh, he's just going to lie? Very cool. It's 200% accurate.
>> Also, the fact that they watch my show is fantastic.
Thank you for the uh Please uh I don't know if you're a subscriber
on an alt or something, or you've been gifted by fake name, but
I appreciate your contribution to the >> Anyone saying
otherwise is coping, lmao. >> I can't believe how viral
that clip has >> It's been awesome. >> It proves
to me that >> I don't know. Where is this clip viral?
Like is it on LSF? >> Like my irrelevance has been
>> Viral on Twitter. >> I haven't seen this get like
pushed to my feed. >> It has been a choice.
>> It's cuz you got everybody blocked who makes fun of
you, you fat
Yeah, you're not going to see it because everybody liking it
and sharing it, you have blocked, idiot. >> We we We watch
Nicholas DeOrio. >> Yes, dude. >> That was awesome.
>> By the way, new donation clip on the >> And coping
over it. And it's so weird. So many of these
>> We WATCH NICHOLAS DEORIO. YES!
>> Coping over it. >> Yeah, they laugh at you. They
laugh at you. They They just laugh at you, bro. >> communities
you'd expect them to not have like weird allegiances in this
way. Like who the [__] cares about Ela Klein? >> Thank
you. >> Well, you guys definitely didn't when you were
friends with her. I'll I'll I'll throw that one out there. I
don't know. I guess the donations are super delayed today cuz
that's going to interrupt me in the middle of my of my ramble.
But so this is what I was talking about. Anisa did like a really
bad impression of of Hila Klein. It sounded like um one of the
guys from The Simpsons. I forgot which one it was. I thought
it was like the fat guy who's like It's not the fat guy. It says
call me. You guys were saying it was like the doctor from The
Simpsons. I don't I haven't watched a lot of the first seasons,
but that's like the good part. Basically, the issue is that Anisa
Jomha and iDubbz have paved their content careers as like >> Oh,
is actually like they're hypocritical? Uh duh. Dude, we already
watched the Chili P video where he totally tore this apart. This
idea, the thing the lying he's doing, right? Actually, it's like
the hypocrisy is what's offen- No, it's not. No, that that wasn't
what you said. That You He spoke at length about it. He tried
to figure out what the accent was. He tried to figure out what
ethnic group it was mocking, right?
And this couldn't do it. As in he really thought it was offensive
just on its own. He was like, "Oh, that's
He didn't think of He didn't think anything about the hypocrisy
element. He just said it was offensive. >> woke scolds
now because iDubbz was known as the guy. He's like taking responsibility
for an entire generation of kids going out and like saying the
and and stuff. So, every time that Anisa gets cornered at any
any given venue, any given avenue, anytime that somebody pushes
Anisa back, she defaults to the exact same behavior that her
and her husband would have done prior, right? But it's it's saved
in a veil of like safe edgy. Back in the day, back in my day
as an >> Why are you trying to read some weird thing into
this? She just did a funny impression of the person cuz they
sound
They have like a cu- cognitively disabled voice.
That's the joke. The joke is you sound like a r-
>> That's you. That's you, Anisa. Sorry.
>> That is Anisa who she's imitating Ela,
That's That's just her. Okay? That's not my fault. That's not
Anisa's fault. That's not Ian's fault. That's not even Nick's
fault. That's just what God gave Ela for a voice, okay? And it's
funny to point out >> nearly 30-year-old washed drama YouTuber,
we used to abide by a situation by a concept that iDubzz mentioned
where content
context matters. Context matters in relation to what's being
said. It's the reason why Team Star calling a black guy the n-
is significantly more damning, at least to me and the majority
of my audience, than Ninja accidentally saying the n- while he's
singing a song in in Fortnite, right? There's the gre- >> Uh
sure. That has nothing to do with the hypocrisy argument. It
doesn't become more offensive because they're social justice
warriors. >> to this thing. PewDiePie saying the n- on
the bridge means that he probably says the n- word in private
more than you'd like PewDiePie to say. Somebody singing the n-
word while they're in the car in white chicks,
I I don't know if that person is really trying to be super edgy
and offensive.
>> I s- I used to think this guy had like
like he thought through things fairly
I This is another moment where I'm starting to realize this guy's
actually just dumb. And he had smart people around him. And he's
blocked and banned at basically every intelligent person. And
now Now that he's surrounded by r- he's got r-
Many s- I How many cases How many times do we have to watch it
happen where somebody seems intelligent and then they start getting
way too self-conscious? They start getting way too ban-heavy,
block-heavy, okay? They piss off their audience. They lose the
smart people from their audience, and then they look
stupid.
You never No, he seems smart even in private, but I think it's
cuz he was talking to people who are really like plugged in all
the time. Now he doesn't have those people anymore. Now he's
off trying to do his own solo thing, and it's not going so well.
But it's very embarrassing when it happens, right? But when it
comes to context mattering in the current day, it's more of like
what side are we allowed to bully? If it's a British guy, you
could say whatever the [__] you want because the
British. Haha, look how based I am. You can make all the same
types of arguments that you can make about gay people or all
this other stuff. You could target the British and wait.
But there he's not There she's not targeting Ela because she's
That's not what's >> You're you're you're safe, edgy. You're
cool. It's okay. Also, if you decide that a group of people are
like ontologically evil, you could target those people till the
cows come home. We don't operate under context mattering anymore.
We actually operate under um no good uh sorry, no bad >> Explain
how the context is bad. He just explained how the context is
>> bad tactics, only good targets now.
So the type of response where in this case she's belittling a
person, this is their second language, right? That she's doing
like a an Israeli accent as well. That's like
How is she doing an Israeli accent? >> another aspect to
it. Um that is okay because the target that she's going after
isn't a
>> So he's just explaining why he finds it offensive. Okay,
never mind. He comes back and doubles down on why it's offensive.
Not actually, right?
Not anything to do with any of this stuff. Not anything. Just
Hey, here's why it's offensive. >> proved attack target.
Like you're allowed to do that. I've talked about this at nauseam
about how I think um how I think like accents are funny and I
wish that accents would come back. Like I can't sit here and
do a MetroPCS talk and text gimmick even though I don't have
any hatred for those people because people get offended by it.
But if I go like "Crikey, I'm going to the Outback Steakhouse."
everybody's like "Yes, dude. Yes, king. That's really funny."
And partially that's because my viewers are not Australian and
they're asleep every time I go live.
But I also the context matters thing definitely applies here
as well. If I go on my stream right now and I say like uh
"YOU BRING GREAT DISHONOR TO YOUR FAMILY." or something like
that. I'm a big fan of Call of Duty Zombies. I mean no harm when
I say that. That's significantly more different than this that
I hate when I sit here and I make fun of her accent. Right? That's
that's obviously a completely different >> He's just he's
going down the he's just catcalls. Can't wait for the Nicholas
Deorio estrogen plus boob job arc, okay.
Good one. Good one. Nicholas Deorio fart just around the corner.
"Um it's just [clears throat] so offensive. You're just making
fun of her for being Israeli." No, she sounds like Lurch, okay.
What is this guy's problem?
>> Uh that's a completely different thing.
>> But even that but even that
He didn't get him. Send him to LS app. Yeah. Oh my god, Nick.
Pride of the The thing is the type of response that Anisa and
iDubbz give are kind of in line with the stuff that they would
have joked about or said before, but now it's all like
it's it's cool. You're going You're going after the the approved
people. And once they step out of line they're going to be the
N-word people again. They're going to be the CEO of racism.
Uh they're going to be the guys
>> I This This totally delusional. This whole thing was
totally delusional.
Honestly, I'm shocked he went away from the lie about it just
being about hypocrisy. He's just explaining how it is offensive
to people, how it is offensive to him. >> Who created the
content? >> Oh, I used to I used to like accents, but like
um um >> The cop that brought a whole army of kids to go
>> He's like straddling both tapes at the same time. >> They're going
to be the people again. They're going to be the CEO of racism.
And it will it will happen. And I can do that on my stream. I
can make like an edgy accent or an edgy joke and not lose any
viewers. You have to be really careful uh in an audience of piranhas
that are going to eat your face when you [__] up.
They're going to eat like that
>> Okay, why can't you just admit that it's funny it sounds
like Ethan Klein?
Just admit that it's really funny. You thought it was really
funny. If if they're around piranhas and you're not, can't you
just admit that it was a funny Ethan Klein impression? He He
says this, okay? He's
Again, this is projection. I feel like it's the same movie that
the Chud, right? It's the same projection.
Uh you're terrified of your audience, Chud Logic. Come to find
out he's the guy who's terrified of Chud's audience. It's like
the same thing. You guys are surrounded by piranhas. He knows
the second he the Kleins, it's over.